you guys I am going to explain the horrific federal lawsuit
brought last week by the male attorney generals of Missouri
Kansas and Idaho
let's get into it first
you need to understand how we got here
so you may or may not know that last term
a Supreme Court heard a case brought by a group of anti choice doctors
who were trying to get mifepristone
a really common abortion medication
off the market for all women throughout the United States
the anti choice emergency room doctors said that they were personally harmed
by mifepristone being on the market
because a woman could take mifepristone
and hypothetically have complications with it
come into the emergency room
and they would have to help her
and they would be personally harmed by that
because they would not want to help her
because they wouldn't want to be complicit in her abortion
as if emergency room doctors get to pick and choose who they treat
based on what LED them into the emergency room anyways
they purposely filed suit in the district of Amarillo
so that they could put the case in front of this anti choice judge
Judge Matthew Kacsmaryk here was like yeah
you guys are really onto something
and he and his individual
infinite scientific medical wisdom decided that the FDA was wrong
and this actually and all of the other medical research on this drug
everybody's wrong and it's actually not safe for women
and he also relied on a law from the 1800s
that prohibited mailing abortifations through the mail
and he said that we should apply that to women trying to get mifepristone today
case went up to the 5th Circuit
who agreed with Judge Kacsmaryk
and then in a concurrence
Judge Ho here was like I'm actually gonna take this a step further
I believe that doctors suffer an aesthetic injury when they view ultrasounds
and develop an attachment to the fetus
and then a woman gets an abortion
because the doctors really wanted to see this grow into a baby
and they got really attached to it
I can't make this stuff up
then it made its way up to the Supreme Court
and the Supreme Court was hesitant to take mifepristone off the market
right before an election
because they knew of the impact that would have on the election
they threw the case out on a procedural ground
not on the merits they didn't really say anything about medication abortion
they just said that it was the wrong plaintiff springing the lawsuit
and they threw the lawsuit out
we got a lot of headlines like this
that made the public believe that the Supreme Court had done something
that was in favor of medication abortion
when they really didn't do that at all
it had gotten thrown out on a procedural ground
if anything they basically wrote an opinion that was like
these are the wrong plaintiffs
and if you wanted to succeed in this lawsuit
here's how you could do so
which leads us to where we are now
so last week instead of a group of anti choice doctors bringing this lawsuit
these three attorney generals from Missouri
Kansas and Idaho have basically refiled the suit
they say they are the right plaintiffs to bring this lawsuit
because they have a duty to protect women and girls
by forcing us to carry unwanted pregnancies
even though they're in Missouri
Kansas and Idaho
they filed it um
in the city of Amarillo Texas
so that they can be in this guy's court
they're also saying the FDA screwed up
we're right they're wrong
Mifepristone isn't safe and they're asking the court
among other things
to make mifepristone unavailable to anyone after *seven* weeks of pregnancy
where most people don't even know that they're pregnant
require three in person appointments
no longer allow anyone to receive it through telemedicine
which is currently how one in five patients get it
because they have an enacted total abortion ban states
so they know that some women in their states are still receiving medication
abortion through the mail
and they wanna make sure that the women in their states
who become pregnant all give birth
they are basically trapped in the states
a lot of these anti choice states
have also been trying to find ways
to prohibit women from traveling out of state to get an abortion
for the same reason they wanna trap women in these states
but don't forget that if they succeeded at this lawsuit
it would affect women nationwide
not just women in Missouri
Idaho and Kansas
they wanted to leave it up to the states
remember let's also be clear that mifepristone is safer than Tylenol
and it is safer than Viagra
it is far safer than forcing women and girls
literal children to continue pregnancies against their will
so their goal is to just boop boop
boop up to the Supreme Court
who after the election
may be more palatable to restricting access to abortion medication nationwide
and trust me they're gonna try to gaslight everybody
they're gonna say oh no
we're not trying to take mifepristone off the market
we're just putting in common sense restriction or language like that
3 in person appointments
and you have to do it before you're seven weeks pregnant
no one is going to be able to do that
no one will be able to access mifepristone
there is so much more to say about this
the complaint was honestly
one of the most disgusting things that I have ever read
um but this is already four and a half minutes
so we're gonna take a pause here
let me know what questions you have in the comments and if you wanna learn more
and I'm the feminist lawyer
follow me if you enjoy being miserable